dancing on the
[Music]
desk do you know why what was the
thought process there so first of all I
didn't write that part that was some of
our Ecentric Michael's intro is at least
kind of gay it's at least kind of but
then I I kind of liked it because here
my thought was Media Matters it's kind
of gay but I kind of like it but I kind
of liked it because I'm pretty and witty
and the Media Matters they're always
trying to say noes is a homophobe he
he's going to like throw gay guys off
rooftops like the Taliban or whatever
and I thought a great way to counteract
that is in the show I can have my really
traditional rhetoric right and I have
the gayest intro but if I have gayest
intro of of not just any conservative
talk show of any show yeah ever
including queer ey for the straight eyy
if I have that it's going to balance out
and kind of trick them